on the road to isiam
there is a sign which reads
russian soldier you've been sent to hell
it is a warning and a threat issued by
ukrainian troops after three weeks of
fighting for this city
and the battle has only just begun
amid the diplomatic chatter the talk of
de-escalation and mutual trust
we saw ukrainian troops getting ready
digging in and re-equipping for the
difficult days ahead
they are fortifying the local road
system building
barricades with concrete and blocks of
granite and we have seen hundreds of
troops perched on the top of armored
vehicles moving up to the front i mean
the fighting there has been intense
but it's clear the ukrainians expected
to intensify
the city of israel is now unreachable
and the villages that surround it have
been flattened by russian artillery and
airplanes
there are bomb craters here as big as a
house
yet the mood of ukrainian troops is high
russia's much vaunted military seems to
instill little fear
they will not pass as an engineer
who also swore at vladimir putin
then the russian military reminded us
they weren't very far away
[Music]
their boundless confidence came as
something of a surprise despite weeks of
intense combat
these men were not afraid
do you feel vulnerable in one of these
things i mean there are
russian planes circling overhead
they may feel confident of victory but
many here are scared
we've seen hundreds of local residents
heading west in their own self-organized
convoys
but that's not an option for the people
of israel
it's encircled by the russians with some
twenty thousand stuck inside
we met a man who managed to escape
israel by foot he didn't want to reveal
his identity his relatives remain in the
city
[Music]
he left the city as a member of a group
of eight swimming through an icy river
then walking for miles
the damage is extensive touching
everyone and everything
and the positioning and appeals of the
negotiating teams feel very far away
john sparks sky news on the outskirts of
isiam eastern ukraine